Let's go to our caller from the six, seven,
eight area code.
Who's calling today from six, seven, eight?
Hey, David.
My name is Anthony Anthony.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can.
OK.
So my question is with Connew, was presidential
announcement.
Do you think there's any chance that he gets
on the debate stage?
And if so, what do you think the dynamic would
be with him front and Biden all up on there?
No.
So listen, here's the deal.
Cut.
Kanye West has said that he struggles with
bipolar disorder.
It's very clear that Konya W is is quite ill.
I saw some reports in the last 24 to 48 hours
that he's in the middle of a bipolar episode
right now.
I don't know if that's true, but it's being
alleged.
I don't I think that this is a complete distraction.
I don't think black folks are going to vote
for.
I don't think black votes are going to switch
their vote to Kenya because Kenya happens
to be black.
I just don't even want to give this attention.
He's not going to be on the debate stage.
To my knowledge, he's not done any of the
things to actually formally be running for
president.
I think it's just nonsense.
And I don't want to risk distracting from
the very real danger of not removing Donald
Trump in November, which needs to be, you
know, Biden is the guy that can win and we've
got to remove Trump.
Yeah, I actually completely agree with that.
I'm a big Tarnya fan.
But somewhere it looks like I think you might
just back out within a few weeks or so.
I think this was just a spur of the moment
thing that he came up with.
Yeah.
And again, back out.
As far as I know, you get like I can say,
I'm running for president if I don't actually
go through the process of of of formalizing
that.
Am I really running for president like it
does nothing for him to even back out of yet?
Yeah, exactly, yeah, yeah.
All right, Anthony, very good.
Great to hear from you.
And an important opportunity to mention, I
think Connew West is ill and I don't think
we should pay too much attention to it.